all right let's keep going and get
caught up on a whole bunch of other
stuff there is a new filing from Donald
Trump's attorneys related to the search
warrant raid served on Mar-A-Lago the
documents that he had in his house etc
etc and if you look through the legal
argument the filing from Donald Trump's
lawyers they make a shocking admission
in the filing and it has to do with some
quotes quotation marks are effectively a
shocking admission here
David how is that possible how is it
possible that quotation marks are a
shocking admission well the use of these
quotation marks expose the level of
desperation that these lawyers are now
exhibiting and it has to do with
quotation marks around the word
classified
in a number of spots in this legal
filing Trump's lawyers put quotes around
the word classified when talking about
classified documents and they decry in
the filing that the government has
unilaterally determined that these are
so-called classified documents think
about that think about the level of
desperation that you have reached when
you're legal filing
attacks the fact that the government and
the government alone has determined
documents are classified and you call
that classification into question with
quotation marks who else determines the
classification of documents who else
gets to decide
and when you are experiencing it's one
of two such brain rot
or such desperation that in order to
assemble what is an attempted defense of
your client's actions you have to put in
quotes the word classified and act as
though it's illegitimate or wrong that
yeah the government deter when we talk
about classified documents
we're talking about the government what
you does Apple get to decide what are
classified documents no corporations can
have Trade Secrets sure but of course
it's the government that has decided
what is a classified document and here
the entire legal filing is based around
the idea and I'm not going to spend a
lot of time on this it's just to kind of
let you know where things stand
the legal filing is based on the idea
of trivializing classified information
now remember at first it was the FBI
planted the stuff this wasn't even stuff
Trump had and then it was well Trump had
Declassified all of the stuff and then
of course that fell apart because it
just doesn't work that way even William
Barr Trump's own former Attorney General
said you can't just go Declassified and
everything's Declassified it doesn't
work that way then we determined that in
fact the classification status of many
of these documents is not relevant to
the statutes under which Donald Trump is
being investigated but put that aside
they don't seem to care about that now
they've moved on to trivializing the
concept of something being classified
and whether the classifier is legitimate
when the classifier is obviously the
government this is obviously chaos all
created by Donald Trump's actions but
they are adding to the chaos Trump's
lawyers added to the chaos by requesting
a special master and then now they're
telling the judge you got to stop this
chaos well this is chaos of your own
creation these are absolutely and
completely total clowns though by the
way the word that should be in quotes is
lawyers not classified and we'll see
whether this works out or whether it
goes anywhere one of our sponsors is all
form the easiest way to design your own
custom sofa I have one from all form
unlike other companies all form lets you
choose the fabric the size the shape
color even the color of the legs I have
not one but two all form sofas I've had
them for years they look good as new
definitely the most comfortable
Furniture I own and it gets even cooler
because all form sofas are completely
modular you can buy a sofa and if you
move you can adapt it to the new space
by adding on to it or rearranging its
elements that is definitely not
something you get from your typical Sofa
Company all form has everything from
eight piece sectionals to love seats and
armchairs everything is made in the USA
using premium materials all form makes
sure that assembly is really easy I
didn't even need any tools which is good
because I have very few tools and you
can keep the sofa for over three months
and send it back free if you don't like
it for a full refund right now all form
is giving my audience 20 off all orders
at allform.com Pacman the link is down
below